[Música]
aquí comienza un nuevo capítulo de medio
ambiente bienvenidos hoy hablamos del
oro blanco el litio un elemento esencial
para la transición energética porque es
el más utilizado en las baterías
recargables que se usan desde teléfonos
móviles y laptops hasta vehículos
eléctricos y las reservas de energía
eólica y solar por eso asegurar el litio
se ha convertido en una prioridad pero
no se produce en cualquier lugar si bien
Australia es el mayor productor del
mundo china es un actor clave además de
ser el tercero con más producción puede
refinar hasta un 60% de litio mundial y
convertirlo en baterías solo la Unión
Europea le compra el 97% de su litio a
China otros actores relevantes son chile
y Argentina que importan por sus
reservas estos dos países y Bolivia
conforman el Triángulo del litio donde
está cerca del 60% de las reservas de
este elemento y a diferencia del que se
produce en Australia que se extrae de
rocas en Minas el litio de este
triángulo está en salares los que más
litio tienen son los de atacama uyuni y
oros
pero aunque en el futuro de litio podría
estar en los salares latinoamericanos su
producción afecta el agua para extraer
el litio se necesita secar las salmuera
al sol durante meses y según la
organización alemana pan para el mundo
para fabricar una sola batería de un
vehículo eléctrico con el litio que se
saca del salar de atacama se
necesitarían evaporar 80.000 litros de
agua para hablar del tema estamos con
Álex Godoy director del centro de
investigaciones en sustentabilidad de la
Universidad del desarrollo en chile y
además él está en Boston porque es
profesor visitante de la Universidad de
Harvard Alex Gracias por estar con
nosotros y cuéntanos cuáles son las
afectaciones ambientales de la
extracción del litio A ver primero es
donde están ubicados los salarios
andinos están ubicados en lugares en los
cuales Lamentablemente se sobrelapan a
lo que es una actividad Industrial
minera por ejemplo en algunos casos
agrícolas ya Y esta actividad minera
obviamente requiere agua estas aguas
provi obviamente desde el altiplano que
son aguas fósiles aguas muy antiguas
napas subterránea en las cuales la
biodiversidad del salar depende de la
humedad existente y de estas napas
subterráneas y esta cantidad de agua que
está ahí el hecho de extraer estos
fluidos lo que uno hace es técnicamente
drenar el agua del salar e irlo secando
en el tiempo entonces los salares se
secan se convierten en cristales sin
fluidos y obviamente sin esa existencia
de agua Todo lo que es la vida que vive
la interfaz agua sal Se va perdiendo lo
que son digamos microorganismos
vegetales etcétera que están
acostumbrados en esos ambientes se van
perdiendo de hecho por ejemplo muchos
flamencos por ejemplo en salar de
atacama viven de microalgas los
flamencos son rosados bien de microalgas
que son existentes de ahí y que
obviamente lean esa diversidad son
ecosistemas sensibles que no tienen un
valor comercial propiamente tal más allá
que las sales que les permiten tener uso
en sistemas
otro dilema es si hay hilito suficiente
para sustentar la transición energética
el consumo global del litio creció más
de un 180% entre 2018 Y 2022 a medida
que los vehículos eléctricos aumentaron
y como cada vez es más demandado su
precio se está duplicando Y hasta
triplicando qué alternativas hay
las reservas de litio van a permitir en
algún minuto
ajustar la transición en términos de
aumentar la producción de batería y de
vehículos no obstante Si nosotros
proyectamos la demanda debiéramos
esperar al año
2030-2040 una especie de más o menos 20
años un Gap en el cual si nosotros no
recuperamos el litio que vamos a estar
usando en baterías
automóviles o en otros sistemas
autónomos debiéramos deberíamos esperar
un agotamiento del litio La pregunta es
qué va a pasar en ese minuto
lo que yo creo es buscar alternativas al
litio y una de las alternativas de litio
son otro tipo de Sales hoy día se están
utilizando y ya existe el primer
vehículo comercial en en China que
utiliza baterías de
cloruro de sodio que es la sal de mesa
la que Nosotros comemos usualmente no
obstante tiene simplemente un 40% de
potencial de ser usado en términos de lo
que se utiliza en el litio por lo tanto
es una podríamos decir es una batería de
más baja calidad Ya vimos que la
reservas de litio están más que todo en
América Latina pero la tecnología para
convertir la batería la tiene el norte
global hay un desbalance allí
la transición entre comillas si lo
miramos en términos globales va a ser
verde dado que supuestamente los
supuestos que hay es que Obviamente tú
vas a tener una reducción de emisiones
en la vista de que utilizas auto
eléctricos batería eléctrica etcétera el
problema Está que el proceso o el camino
para alcanzar ese punto de equilibrio
significan impactos socioambientales y
económicos en los países de extracción
que es la típica ecotomía entre los
países extra de una economía extractiva
con los países que demandan o sea cuánto
del empobrecimiento de chile Bolivia o
Argentina y empobrecimiento en términos
no del ingreso por litio sino en
términos de impacto ambientales impacto
a las comunidades van a quedar en el
hemisferio sur y no van a ser
transferidos
a la hoja de para los países del Norte
es decir la extracción de litio en
términos mineros conlleva impactos
ambientales bastante grandes y va a
llevar un impacto ambiental de la
pérdida de salares porque va a tener que
ser así porque así es en la minería
extractiva entonces muchas veces
crecimiento producción de los vehículos
va a estar en el hemisferio norte que
son los que le van a entregar el valor
agregado tecnológico a vehículos que al
final nosotros mismos vamos a tener que
comprar Entonces el círculo es nosotros
extraemos desde los países mineros litio
que va a dar a los países desarrollados
para la producción de autos que van a
exportar esos autos precisamente a los
países que estamos en vías de desarrollo
por tanto es un círculo que al final se
va replicando y lo que no sabemos es
Quiénes son los que van a ganar y
quiénes son los que van a perder y un
círculo en el que una posible solución
según nos dijo usted antes es la
transferencia de tecnología Álex Gracias
por estar con nosotros y a ustedes les
recordamos que pueden ver este y todos
los capítulos en 24.com